大家好,今天我将为大家带来面向昇腾Triton开发的初级课程
首先会给大家整体的介绍一下Triton的背景和原理,以及昇腾上使用的方案
在当前的时代,我们的AI应用主要是跑在GPU、NPU这种AI处理器上
由于我们的算力需求飙升,这种具有高平行效率的处理器承载这些AI产品中的算力
在这些处理器上执行训练和推理,可以获得大幅度的性能提升
我们的模型和网络通常是由大量的算子组成
对行业内的开发者和使用者来说,面向这些AI处理器对于算子进行开发和调试调优是工作的一大重点
一些厂商会提供面向处理器的编程模型,比如应用家的CUDA,还有华为昇腾的Ascend C
这些都是类C或C++的语言
支持客户写出非常高性能的算子
这种编程方式提供了很多和硬件底层相关的接口
来支撑用户去做非常细度的手动调优,去把性能进行的往上推
但是随着芯片微架构的逐渐发展演化
处理器的结构变得更加复杂
用户在编写算子的时候就需要根据处理器的微架构
去做越来越多的性能控制
对GPU来说甚至需要CUDA级别的编程来对每一个线程进行调度
这样虽然可以使算子的性能达到很高的一个程度
但是开发的难度也越来越高
因为这种编程方式的代码通常比较长
对于学习成本开发门槛都比较高
而且需要开发者去足够了解芯片的底层架构
像共享内存管理还有什么同步这些底层操作
其实都需要开发者去自己来控制
但是对开发者来说呢
他们的需求不是单一的
性能不是他们唯一的标准
开发者面向的场景多种多样
而且开发者自己的背景和经验也各不相同
并不是所有的场景都需要这么去追求算子的性能
所以呢也诞生了对高效编程的需求
关于开发者的编程需求呢
我们大概的可以根据他们的场景
还有开发者的背景来做一个分类
在这些类别里呢就更适合高效的开发来达到一个较高性能的
这种编程方式
首先是算法研究
这样的开发者呢他需要快速的去开发新模型的一些算子
或者说做一些自己的算子定制
对他们来说呢效率是很重要的
他们需要拿最快的速度来打通原型
或者说他们有时候会做一些算法上的快速迭代
还有一种呢就是说我们要做跨硬件平台部署的模型
我们需要把相同的算子呢来在各种硬件上都做一个运行
那这种情况下呢我们就需要尽可能的避免
我和同一个算子在多种硬件上去做重复的开发去给不同的实现
来给硬件生态做一个解耦
那为什么高效开发的方式可以达成这一点呢
是因为一般来说高效开发的方式都屏蔽了大部分的硬件的细节
来支撑这种跨平台的模型部署
还有呢就是说我们非性能瓶颈的算子
这些算子呢他在功能上非常关键
但是呢在整体的模型的时间上呢
模型的时间上呢他的时间占比较小
或者说性能挖掘的潜力比较低
那这种算子呢就不值得我们去费很大劲
去把他的性能给拉高
然后对开发者来说呢
我们很多开发者是比如说刚入行
对硬件的熟悉程度不足
或者说是我们的学生群体
对他们来说呢
如果对硬件不够了解的话呢
是很难写出极致性能代码的
他们也就适合拿这种高效开发的方式来做一个入门
而下面这几个类型呢就更需要我之前提到的那种底层的开发方式来实现对于算子的深度性能调优
比如说我们的基础库的开发维护
那这些算子呢会需要频繁的调用
而且对模型的整体性能影响也非常的明显
或者说我们的这些算子呢本身就是性能瓶颈算子
我们在这些算子上呢就需要做重点的性能突破
还有就是一些超低延迟的应用场景
比如说自动驾驶
那对这些产品来说呢
那性能就是我们的最高需求
我们就不惜一切代价
愿意花很多的时间去对我们的算子进行一个调用
还有呢就是我们的对硬件的开发经验丰富的人员
他们呢对这种硬件有足够的了解
有充足的经验和能力
来支撑他们对高性能算子的开发实现
而且他们同时呢还会及时了解硬件的更新
并且利用上硬件的新特性
对这些人来说呢
他们就很适合这种高难度高门槛
同时能达成这个高度这个性能标准的这种编程方式
那这两种编程方式呢其实是可以搭配使用的
并不是说一定要选择其中一种就一直在用
我们通常来说呢可以用高效开发的这种方式
来快速实现我们的创新
或者说我们一些整体的新模型里的算子
来把我们的开发效率红利给享受到
在我们实行完这个快速打通之后呢
我们再在里面去识别我们算子的性能表现
去找到我们的关键的热点算子
或者说性能表现不太好的算子
然后呢我们再用第二种方式
那种控制硬件底层细节的编程方式
去做这个深度的调优来压榨算子的性能
所以说对开发者来说呢
他们是既需要我们的深度性调优的方式
也需要高效开发的方式
所以我们就诞生了Triton的这种编程语言
那这里就给大家讲一下什么是Triton呢
Triton就是可以支撑高效率的开发的
一个编程语言和编译器的结合体
它呢就不仅仅是一个单纯的语言前端
除了我们开发者去使用的这种语言层
其实还包括下面的面向硬件后端的
自动优化的编译器层
那因为我们之前提到过这种高效开发的
编程方式呢
它其实简化了用户对硬件的控制
那这一部分的硬件控制相关的优化呢
就会由编译器去做自动的实现
而Triton呢就是由我们前端的DSL
还有后面基于MLIR的编译器的部分
组成的一个编译框架
那Triton呢它是由OpenAI做的一个产品化
做出了一款一个坚固高性能和高易用的
编程模型来降低GPU入门的编程难度
原本是一个对面向GPU的一个编程方式
那它可以做到就是对硬件
无关的一个算的开发能力
可以用过庞大的开源生态
让这个多后端的硬件
去复用一套前端的DSL接口
然后呢在MLIR的这个阶段呢
可以看到它先是做了一层
针对GPU通用的方言表达
然后呢在后期呢就转换成了
不同的LLLVM的编译路径
然后再转换成对不同硬件的一个指令
这样呢它就可以做到一套代码
在多种不同的后端的处理器上运行
也不需要开发者对代码做什么复杂的修改
这样呢可以在生态上更加的开放
对于多硬件平台的迁移成本呢也可以做到更低
而在前端语言方面呢
转换成它提供了就是GPU Python的DSL
就是类Python的语法
大家都知道现在Python可以说是
AI领域的主流语言有丰富的工具链生态
比如说像是那个PyTorch
TensorFlow这种AI框架
还有像NumPy这种基础的计算库
而且AI领域内呢
本身Python的开发者数量就很多
再加上这个Python的动态类型
还有简洁的语法
可以说本身这种Python开发就代表了易用性
大部分开发者也更熟悉
除此之外呢
Triton还采用了这种分块编程的方式
可以一般叫tile或者block
那这种相比CUDA的编程方式呢
我们数据管理的粒度更大
编程抽象的级别也更高
可以有效的去降低算子的开发门槛
来提升这个开发的效率
使开发者的算子编写呢
上手更加的容易
我们上次刚刚说了Triton它是那种tile级编程
那什么是tile级编程呢
其实我们可以拿大概我们这个数据的分块大小来形容一下
那我们如果是最高的抽象
我们大家就是不管数据的切分
直接把整个的一个Tensor
就拿来计算
那这个我们可以叫Tensor Level
这种呢
其实我们开发者就只管计算逻辑就完了
也不用管里边数据怎么去做并行
然后呢Triton呢
这就是下面这一层
这一层呢
它其实就是说让开发者呢
我们去手动的给一个数据进行一个大概的分块
来指导一下它们的这个并行的行为
但是呢我们又不会把块内的这些计算呢
去做一种像线程级的控制
这种方式呢就可以把很多并行细节给隐藏掉
比如说我们的内存合并啊
一些这个共享内存管理
或者说一些在那个对GPU来说
一些SM内的这种调度
其实就开发者就不用来管
他们只需要管呢
我们怎么对数据的一个切分
还有说让他们怎么在这个多个核上去做这个并行
但是呢这个数据的切分呢
它只是一种表现方式
其实总体来说呢
它最核心就是说它的这个抽象层次
它是一种屏蔽了大部分底层细节的这种编程方式
也就是说呢
我们如果说把创层次从高往下顺的话
那其实现在说越高层的抽象
就有更多的工作呢
是由编译器来完成
而越底层的抽象呢
就有更多的硬件的控制呢
是让开发者自己来完成
那这种情况下呢
现在说我们越靠底层
开发的能力就会更高
但是呢
编译器它的这个优化呢
通常来说会比我们的人工来说更加的保守
因为对编译器来说它的一个最重要的一点就是要保证这个
就是结果的正确性
但是对开发者来说呢
他就会有比如说个人的经验
额外的信息
来让他们去做那种编译器无法做到的这种调优
所以说呢
高层高抽象层次的编程语言呢
他在我们短时间内
或者说比如说我们
用快速开发的方式来说
他能很快的达到一个较高的性能能
那比如说我们来看一下这个
23年的这个GTC大会上
这个图就是很明确的
点出了这几种开发方式的这个区别
那Triton呢他自己的抽象层次更高
也是开发的易用性最高
可以看到他在很短的这个开发时间内呢
快速的达到一个相当高的一个性能
这一点呢就是像CUDA和C++来
对他们来说就是做不到的
因为短时间内开发的方法
因为细节不够
所以性能呢通常就比较差
但是如果开发者我们去花很多时间来做
就是做针对性的调优
通过我们手工来补充这个硬件细节来说呢
那后面越底层的这种编程方式
我们其实就可以做到的优化就越多
所以你看在这个出现层次最低的这个C++来说
它最后的最终的性能反而会更高
那这个就是当然也是需要开发者去用他们的这个时间来做到这一点
那这个就是几种不同抽象层次的开发语言之间的一个差异
而Triton呢它的主要的就是这种比较高的抽象
然后来隐藏底层的细节
来达到这个高效编程的一个能力
接下来呢我们给大家讲一下这个在昇腾上是如何支持Triton呢
那我在课程前面提到过
Triton的诞生之初呢是面向GPU的编程和编译
但是华为的昇腾是NPU
所以我们就做了对应的组件来实现了和社区Triton的对接
还是相同的Triton的算子写法
但是呢就可以在我们昇腾的上面去运行
我们呢开发而且开源了这个Triton Ascend
也就是面向昇腾平台的Triton
它呢为Triton的开发者提供了昇腾上的算子快速开发和昇腾迁移的能力
在结构的使用上呢和社区的Triton基本没有区别
是Triton代码在昇腾高效运行的入口
用户的Triton代码呢就会从这里边进入到编译流程
这里边包含了一部分IR的转换还有优化
里边也有Runtime
也就是我们这个算子呢
经过编译之后会通过它里边的运行代码
来控制编译的算子去做执行
而看呢就是我们昇腾针对AI场景
推出了一个计算架构
发挥了这个承上启下的关键作用
向上支持各种AI框架
然后向下连接昇腾的硬件
使各种应用在昇腾上运行
而且提高运行效率的一个平台
里面呢大家可以看到不同层次的组件
比如说这个面向模型开发的各种算子库
还有我们的编程语言
比如Ascend C也是在这里面
再往下呢就是我们的这个毕昇编译器
毕昇编译器呢
也就提供了我们面向昇腾的编译优化的能力
在这里边呢我们开源了一个组件
叫AscendNPU-IR
我们也就通过这一层
来支持的这个Triton的编译能力
也就是说其实所有的MLIR的生态能力呢
都是通过这个AscendNPU-IR来对接到我们的昇腾上
它呢这个AscendNPU-IR呢它不是单独一种方言
而是由不同抽象层次的方言做的一个集合
在这里面呢我们就会对Triton编译过来的MLIR
这个中间语言呢来进行昇腾亲和的编译优化
也就是说我们先进行在这里呢先进行MLIR的编译
然后再进行LLLVM的编译
这些都是在编译器里完成的
最后就会就是可以生成在昇腾上高效运行的二进制
这个主要也是简单带过了
在这里就不细讲了
然后我们可以看一下
这个首先原本的社区的编译流程里呢
它一开始会转换成这个跟硬件无关的这种Triton-IR
再往下呢它就会编译到这个Triton-GPUIR
在这层呢它就会做一些跟GPU相关的一些优化
然后再往下呢就是不同的GPU后段
然后做的这个优化还有代码生成
但是我也提到过啊我们昇腾呢它是NPU
所以说我们在这层呢其实就会和它分叉
在Triton-IR的往下编译的过程呢
我们会编译成MLIR社区的这个Linalg 方言
然后在这个Linalg 方言往下呢
就会这个编译到我们这个开用总价
NPUIR
让它来做往下的编译来生成我们的昇腾二进制
那这个就是我们在昇腾上使用Triton的方式
比如说把这个编译流程算子生成
来迁移到我们的昇腾上
做了一个专门的亲和优化
然后通过这个来完成了我们在昇腾平台上对Triton的迁移